this program is brought to you by Emory
University this afternoon and this is
I'm rosemary Magee and I serve as vice
president and Secretary of the
University and also have been had the
pleasure of hosting a wide range of
creativity conversations with people
visitors members of our own faculty all
across campus and also attending some of
these that others of you have hosted and
it really is an opportunity to think
about the creative process and what
sparks it and how it can be more highly
developed and important part of our both
our individual lives and our lives as a
part of the community and this
conversation in particular came out of
several conversations that my colleague
and I have had and it precedes the Emory
University Symphony Orchestra and chorus
presentation of the world premiere of
John Anthony linens eternal gates which
is next week on the 15th and 16th at the
Schwartz Center and the oratorio is
based on the Egyptian Book of the Dead
which as we know is the ancient funeral
texts which date back to 1500 BCE so
that's the that's the platform that is
the basis for the work and for the
conversation and it's really going to be
a momentous event that many of us are
looking forward to and we thought it
would be important to get some insights
from the composer about about the work
and also about the process and I guess
the first thing I want to say to you
jack is first of all thanks for doing
this and thanks also for the work that
we're about to experience next week and
I'd like to know a little bit more about
the title of it that the title you've
chosen for the work is eternal gates and
give us a sense of context for that why
you chose that and with that what that
points us towards okay well thank you
for having me come to your conversation
this weekend thank you for attending
the title eternal gates has several
connotations and different religions in
the context of the mythology of Egyptian
deities this refers to some degree to a
Mendte
which was a city in Egypt where
supposedly one went to die and go on to
the afterlife and so there's that
reference there of of these gates that
are eternal and deities have to go
through them and the meaning that that
involves and this idea of working with
the material from the Book of the Dead
that is something that's been with you
for a while it's you know something
that's been a part of your thinking your
reflection and I just like for you to
share with us a little bit about how
this idea first came to you and how it
may perhaps have evolved over time maybe
to answer that I could start at the
beginning and work back it's a huge
piece it's an hour long and it involves
a lot of people it's not the kind of
piece that can get performed a lot and
it takes a lot of commitment by a lot of
people to get this to happen and so most
composers include myself wouldn't take
this on unless there was a realistic
chance of actually having it performed
so that you can hear the music and
others can't hear it as well and so that
particularly for this piece involved the
ability to have these forces on campus
all over the campus who who could do
this and are very good in Samba 'ls and
aren't conductors who are willing to
take this on and also on a technological
end of it it involves such a
amount of editing with detail that
without a computer it would have taken
years and years longer to do and it
would have been a barricade to trying to
take on something that big and then a
third part of it is of something I'm
very happy about which is the kind of
Haven that I have that's created by my
wife Camille where I can work quietly
and be undisturbed and concentrate on on
what I'm doing so for me it really has
taken several different elements to come
together to do that in terms of the text
I course been aware of the Book of the
Dead for a long time and I guess it was
six or seven years ago I was reading
through it and casually reading yeah I
can't remember if we were moving books
around or what was happening but I
started looking at it and I and I was
caught again by the the unique feature
where it has the Egyptian hieroglyphs
the Egyptian text and then the English
translation and it's all right there
within 250 pages which is fantastic and
it's in public domain and not this
source hasn't been used exclusively by
any composer that I know of there have
been some snatches like from Akhenaten
that that have some refrains from the
text but that is a literal opera a
historic opera and takes from many
different sources so I was fascinated
that this was kind of an unused text and
in comparing it to other creation myths
or religious creationism it said itself
a part of because it's based on a
mythology not on actual characters like
you would find in the Torah or the the
Bible or the Koran
and that that fascinated me the the
basic element was to try particularly in
these days where there's such conflicts
with religion around the world and
people are not willing to conciliate I
guess with one another this was in in
one sense a an attempt to go back beyond
all the other religions to see a unified
narration that people could address
without bringing whatever it is they
bring to that and there could be some
kind of reconciliation or peace that
might be seen to that way and through
that prism of looking way back to
ancient people that's one of the only
methods that one could use because if we
look around today we're caught in our
Quagmire's and the future is hard to to
predict other than to be imaginative and
and have an outcome for that but anyway
I saw it as actually a door to a world
that has not been utilized and I found
very interesting and of course reading
that the Book of the Dead text which I
did for a long long time is kind of with
a profundity of an amateur where I don't
really know what I'm looking at I'm just
looking to see what I like and how I put
it together and just using my intuition
in that way and when you were missing
this you stated you looked at it again
so it was it was this something that you
had read or studied in your past was it
something that had had an effect on you
and at an earlier point in your life and
then sort of came back to you in a new
form yeah I think the first time I read
the book of the Dead and other kinds of
books like that was Tibetan Book of the
Dead and bhagavad-gita and so forth was
when I was in college and when I was in
college I was a literature major and
I was very interested in the word and
religion I went to a Jesuit school and
we had no rip rhetoric and logic ethics
physics metaphysics religion languages
it was kind of that that type of
curriculum and so there was a lot to be
read there and of course at that time I
was in school in the late sixties early
seventies and there was a lot of
questions as like 10 or 15 years after
Time magazine stated that God was dead
and I remember having uh actually you
know that relates back of course the
Emory campus I remember having a teacher
father BOE's Nicky who he was polish and
had just come to America and at that
time he was probably fifty years old and
in this metaphysics course he
essentially said that God did not exist
and so it created a lot of thought and I
think it from his perspective he had
come from Europe and he had seen
unimaginable destruction and he was
trying to to reconcile his faith and
going through his own crisis in the
classroom maybe was a way for him to
vent that but for the younger for the
students it was a thought-provoking
process to have a priest tell you that
there was no God and why and
these I had to go to this school because
my families everybody had to go to this
school and I grew up in San Francisco
enough where you had to go and my father
had gone there and my father when I was
very young I think I mentioned this that
he one of our rituals at home I have an
older sister he would read to us every
night before we go to sleep you read all
kinds of interesting things you know
everything from Huckleberry Finn to the
lost world or
and rod or whatever might be but
sometimes he would if we ran out of the
book he would just make start making a
story up in which so will tell us more
and he had this ability to just keep
telling a story and sometimes we'd ask
him the next night the next night to
continue with the serialized version and
it would be some kind of horror story
like with green monkeys in the wall who
would come out at night and and had
personality disorders that's kind of
traumatizing well he was a bit on the
dramatic side he would I'd like to
explain Oh like how earthquakes happened
or volcanoes or how the tides worked or
does he he had these kind of amateur
interest and he liked to engage us in
this so I remember when I was very young
he the first memory I have of pyramids
was when he was telling us about how
pyramids were built and the problem of
having these huge stones and how do you
cut him and move them and and how that
might have been done and he said well
how do you think they got the base level
to build a big pyramid because they
couldn't start with an unlevel base
because it would tilt and of course he
knew the answer and he eventually told
us but he would make us think through
well how could you do that which was
pretty much beyond us a small child and
the answer was you dig a big trench and
then you put water in there and you
measure it then you start with your
level base but he was fascinated with
things like that and how how there was
an alignment with us astronomy and so
forth and that caught my attention it
allowed my intent of my imagination I
think to to wander when I was young so
given that basis which sounds like very
imaginative and also mythic and then the
questions that were raised and your
youth by by your teachers by the priests
what is about this tell us a little bit
about the storyline that informs this
work what what drew you to you know how
do you trace that narrative and in the
work that you've now created
and what draws you to that particular
narrative what I did in this text I did
a lot of peripheral reading there
there's a lot to be read about that and
an earlier sources the am droite that
that has that predates the Book of the
Dead by quite a bit of time and it would
have for instance it talks about that
it's the book of gates and it talks
about the hours that that pass kind of
like in the Tibetan Book of the Dead
where it talks in the photos where the
bardos I mean where where each day
there's another progression into the
afterlife and so from there for instance
one of the movements came to be the
gates of heaven and there are twelve
gates so it was kind of using that
imagination there's another text by
Christopher ere that
well not Christopher air I went off
their Welcome Party what I was gonna say
was if excuse me if people would like
what what I did is I took that text from
the The Book of the Dead and then in
these peripheral readings
Christopher Eyre was the cannibal hymns
and in those peripheral texts there are
listings of from the literature what was
being talked about and I took all the
subtitles from particularly the coffin
texts and so I thought I would read that
twelve movements and then the subtitle
so you kind of get a sense of what
happens so the first the first title is
star clock and the description is time
in the beginning are created by the
great deep the prime primal water knew
and after that become comes the island
of flame where raw creates the earth in
the netherworld with light and the third
movements the harpist song the deities
Hathor esis and
or a Cyrus seeing an offering of praise
of raw the creator that never nether
worth netherworld earth and then the
valley of darkness into snow the world
earth evil lurks among set in his fiends
who cannot abide light and truth and who
want the head of Osiris the God of
eternity and the heir of raw and so he
well in the temple of dendron fifth
movement amid wild adulation of good and
evil
Osiris arrives to find the altar well
where he will be sacrificed by the
forces of evil
Osiris asks Raw for resurrection into
heaven that will bring triumph over set
and allow him to reign for eternity then
we go to the sixth movement which is to
him to Osiris and here Isis the divine
sings a hymn of praise of Osiris for his
resurrection into heaven which is
followed by the fiery lake where by boat
rock crosses the lake of fire into death
with his divine followers from the
netherworld into the horizon of
afterlife and of getting through here
movement eight Hathor the goddess of the
sky prays for raw for safe passage into
heaven for Osiris and Isis and for all
blessed Souls then nine the ladder of
the sky Osiris and ISA swallow raw and
lead Hathor the divine and divine
followers into the sky and let's see
gates of heaven which I mentioned
dedede's rise and approached the 12
gates of heaven and asked that they be
opened then eleven the fields of peace
led by rah the Cirrus Jesus and half of
the vine followers glimpsed the fields
of eternal peace and then finally in the
last movement the festival of the
beautiful visit this is where all the
deities come together to have a festival
joy and in this last movement the
audience will join in I hope and sing a
refrain that in Egyptian is forever and
ever for
or endeavor and it's very clear what
what's coming up and the conductor will
turn around and cue people in so some
kind of logistical questions here you
you reference the Egyptian so how much
of the Egyptian did you know or do you
know or how did you how did you attain
the knowledge that you needed in order
to do this because the work is actually
you use the Egyptian in it is that right
right what I did I had these subtitles
that that created the narrative then I
took from the Book of the Dead the text
that would fit in a particular movement
so I really arranged the text I didn't
write it I only had to make some slight
alterations to have some grammatical
consistency in a few spots I wouldn't
claim to know Egyptian right it's just
that I kept looking at the text and
looking at it until it started there was
a coherence that that made sense I would
spend hours like looking for the word he
or
hours looking for another word and then
I over a long time I put it together I
think there were about 25 edits like a
panel yeah to get it to the point where
it is at this point and then how did you
connect the the ideas that you had and
the the stories the narrative and the
ideas to the actual music what was that
what was the connecting point so you so
you could you could imagine it you could
hear it you could feel it what how does
that magical composition occur because
you've got a concept but it becomes
embodied I think it's the oral
imagination where say if a composer is
given a visual or a story or something
like that it's pretty natural to start
ascribing sound to this you know the
dramatic underlying sound of what
happens and so going back to this idea
how the pyramids were built I was
thinking well what would it have been
like the music what would it have been
like at that time so we know
from descriptions that what some of the
instruments were and how they were used
we know that they they had ritual music
in temples and in pyramids these are
young voices like 18 25 years old they
didn't live very long so the voices
would have had a certain quality and
they sang sometimes solo or in groups
there would be ambient sound in these
large spaces so you would get some echo
and some kind of ambient acoustic sound
and also they did processions so you can
imagine some things would be in too but
also there are descriptions one early
one is from Herodotus from I think the
4th century BCE where he talks about
Egyptian music and how it has its own
kind of music but you can find similar
music in Syria at the time and then
later in Greece and he describes a
procession where the system which is a
little metallic instrument could be put
in Iraq and they would play that and it
would he says would imitate the sound of
papyrus leaves also he says that the
music is similar to what was found in
Greece a little bit later and also
there's a Roman writer who's how puniest
I believe his name is who described
these rhythms like three beats and
arrests and how that this happened he
saw this in a procession of esis it was
an outdoor procession and had
instruments and part of the reason if
they had a lot of people they would use
something like a system much like in the
military just to keep people in the same
beat together rather than a crowd
wandering around so from that one can
extrapolate a lot of things of what
could be sound could be heard so for me
the instruments are there they speak of
harps or liars the system the sassette
which is another percussion instrument
and of course these are
small little instruments if you've seen
them like in museums or pictures and so
what I wanted to do is blow this all up
like by a thousand times so I'm using a
lot of metallic percussion instead of
these little things and there are a lot
of crowd voices and you knew from the
beginning that it would be an orchestral
work right because I had this chance to
so our opportunity right and so what is
that process then of blowing it up so
not the the types of instruments the
size of the sound the numbers of people
who participate you know from a concept
that you have in the beginning just
something that's a very large-scale
complex involving a lot of moving parts
and pieces and voices and luckily the
voices are of the same age right time
that you would be the historical
references but how do you make that
translation well part of that was again
thinking about what kind of sound they
would use and that would probably have
an acoustic bass being in a resounding
room so octaves and fifths and probably
diatonic motion melodically more so than
then we don't know of course but they
could have used scales within two
nations other than acoustic diatonic ISM
but our singers couldn't do that we
would be there for the next ten years so
I used basic diatonic sounds because
it's a huge piece and so lot for these
young people to put together there's a
time limit and so I gave them what I
thought that would be something they
could get in their ear the difficult is
is not so much in the pitch construction
but in the rhythmic way and then you had
willing collaborators and your
colleagues yes and how hard then it was
it for them is this a work that's
unusual for it for them and for the
orchestra and for
the choruses it seems like it will
probably any new work every work has its
problems in this has its problematic
aspect so I guess you have to or the
conductors take it for for what it is
what the what the difficulties are going
to be really Eric Nelson has the the big
burden because we have so many singers
and they're not all trained players and
there's a lot going on in the music and
it doesn't sound like swanee River so
they have to make that leap of faith I
have put some mp3s on there learn link
file so if they want to go listen they
can do but the mp3s which are sound
samples we may play a sample there it's
really an inadequate substitute it
layers out when you get too much in
there so you you don't hear the
differentiation of all the different
sounds and it can't provide a text which
can be very disorienting and so up to
this point you mentioned earlier when we
were talking privately that they've been
rehearsing in small bits and pieces and
small groups and next week they're gonna
go into the large orchestral and chorus
rehearsal and will you be a part of that
yes they have the choir and a pianist
have been in one building with one score
working on that and the orchestra with
the strings and another place and then
at one point the percussion and winds
then joined them and then they all
joined together next Monday so it'll be
the first time for everybody and of
course there's nothing I can do
so when Eric Nelson comes down the
hallway shaking his head no it's gonna
be exciting right right right
or nodding his head right so one of the
things that you said well I think the
first question I want to ask you and I
want to go back to the
ten of this for a second so why do you
think that The Book of the Dead which
dates back over 3,000 years right why do
you think it's meaningful to us today or
relevant or will it especially I'm
thinking of the young people who are
participating in this as well as the
audience and this this performance is
part of a larger conference that will be
happening on campus on creativity and a
life cycle and that's related to its
premiere so there will be a wide range
of people for both from this campus and
elsewhere and then the students who are
participating in this so from a lot of
different perspectives and vantage
points you know why why is this
particularly meaningful to us today to
me in reading the text you could be
talking to someone sitting next to you
in the library
it's very human and in in this text
liking the temple of dendro where all of
these things are happening good and evil
it's not like it it's filtered out you
only get good things happening there and
it's not quite human and of course it's
not all evil either but there's such a
mixture and the temptations everything
is in this text drugs cannibalism you
name it it's it's in there and so it's
seemed like such a distant but such a
near entity to to make a connection with
I was wondering if when as I was
thinking about this and recent weeks
we've been really inundated with
information about Egypt and about that
whole part of the world and I was
wondering as if you were seeing these
events unfold before us and TV in the
news if you also saw any connection to
this larger historical context as new
voices were being heard or heard a new
way
I'm probably not the one to ask who
knows where the sweep in the Middle East
is going but it's certainly going
somewhere and I think some shackles are
being thrown off and maybe a new
directions going but I don't know if
it's leading to a universality or what
though right yeah more than the
historical part of that or what will
happen in the future I was wondering if
it if it made the the the music and the
material the text will kind of have a
deeper resonance for you as you kind of
saw that arising saw that energy arising
and then in the land of the pyramids
sure pay more attention to what's going
on
but then like I couldn't say I have
first-hand contact with that culture you
know president dead culture inadequate
more to that more to the history of it
you've said in another context that
these ancient people had the same
existential questions and desires that
we struggle with today and what what do
you think those primary existential
questions are that you're referring to
that we struggle with today and that are
in the material they wanted to know what
happens next and they wanted to know
what they could do to propitiate the
gods so that they could go from the
netherworld to the afterlife
thinking that that this the evil that is
in the note the netherworld would be
something to transcend so definitely
there's a there's a future part of it
which is what's going to happen next but
there's also it seems to me implied in
that a present part in that so how do we
how do we live our lives or how do we
think about our lives now in order to
prepare ourselves for the futures that
do you see that part of it as well
my expertise is more music right
inspiration around it so I feel not real
comfortable trying to be a scholar about
it I think there's some similarities but
different you know we have different
cultural ideas but you see the music as
a way of really transcending culture
both in terms of time as well as plays
again going to the universal right I
think there are these universal truths
that much like classicism things come
and go but there's often a return in
between two or more kind of a larger
unified thought who knows if that would
happen again
how does this work relate to some of
your earlier work that you've done is it
part of a is it part of a pattern or
continuum or there are there questions
both musical questions and other
questions that have informed that that
also inform this I was thinking about
that on this piece distinctly looks
backward to look forward and I I did a
piece about two years ago for oboe and
string quartet that actually looked back
to Greece and the island of aiolia and I
usually don't look backward it works
like this year have had three premieres
one in September in Switzerland and it
was a performance art piece titled
the walls of paradise and it's really
about what happens inside the walls of
paradise so it's really looking forward
and to the X to the X distension
happenings or fears or hopes that occur
in the future and then just recently I
had a piece premiered in New York which
was about something that just had our
recent big snowstorm I pretty much wrote
it during that time when I was oh well
Camille know were locked in the house
and we couldn't really get out
and so after the snow we were spoken
well long story but we were stuck in the
house and finally the Sun came out and I
was supposed to write this guitar piece
and so I decided to use the instrument
to write it and whatnot at the piano but
at play at the guitar
and so I I had some ideas about what I
was going to do but I noticed that the
light was coming through the window
across the strings onto the fingerboard
and you could see these shadows of the
fingers and then this the strings and so
as I followed it it was fun to kind of
play with those shadows so it's kind of
what was happening right then so I
titled the piece silhouettes but kind of
ended now so I think composers day they
jump around whatever is - inspiration at
the time but this particular process
required a tremendous amount of research
and so it is you know it is a very
scholarly project yeah because of the
text right and and deer or other works
require that degree of researcher is at
a different kind of mode like in the one
you just described as more a more
present if there's just notes and
rhythms and instruments I don't need to
go anywhere I can go out in the garage
and and work on that if it has a text it
has extra musical characteristics that
affected the music for one thing is it
in public domain
earlier I a number of years back I did
some setting of James Joyce poems penny
each and I was a little naive and I
fortunately got a letter allowing me to
use the text after I'd written that the
music but there are these horror stories
of people who don't quite get there or
can't find a person to give them the
agreement and so some people have really
gotten sidetracked on that issue
hence the benefit of using ancient texts
public domain
can't miss so we've talked we've talked
some about the process and some of the
inspirational qualities of teachers or
text or material and a bit about the
music and you have some of the music
here recorded that we could hear a
portion of it would do you want to play
some of that for us and then provide a
little bit more of a commentary on what
we're hearing we could do that okay
I could play several each of that
movements are three to four minutes so I
think a couple of more around seven
minutes I could play unfortunately on
this device I can't speed up or
fast-forward it it's either you hear the
whole thing or stop it so maybe we could
listen to just a few okay things yeah
now Elizabeth Horner has told me how I
activate this to get so I can plug
oh here we go Oh a minute maybe this I
don't think I have to
I just learned how to to do this
so I thought I play something when
they're crossing the boats crossing the
river at night and the lake the rivers
on fire and that ended the Deiters of
trying to go across to get to the
horizon to the afterworld
Oh
so will you tell us a little bit more
about the oh you're gonna oh wait I'm
trying to stop okay
about what we just heard where that is
in the work and and where it's going
where that where the direction is taking
us so that's the seventh movement which
is I'm sorry
those are sound samples and so it's kind
of hard to hear the detail but this is
where raw is leading the boat and
they're going through the water so you
hear the strings are kind of rolling and
they're trying to make this passage
across through the night over this lake
on fire to get to the rise and and go
through the horizon to the west which
leads them to the afterlife and of
course all the deities if if they make
it then the rest of the deities can make
it and they can have this world in the
afterlife so when you and I talked about
it before and you played some of the
parts for it there each of these
sections has really very distinctive
mood to it and which is is largely
informed of course by the story and by
the text to create that mood but but
really requires you to to be in a
different kind of space or mood I would
think as a composer some of it being a
very very high energy or some of it
being very joyful other of it being more
questioning or more serene and so how is
it that you can create those states
within yourself in order for it to be
reflected in the music how does that
work well each of the movements has its
own character its own themes and the
hope is that the overall typography
dramatically works and I mean that
that's part of the interconnected issue
the kind of goes back is the same
element that when you have mold amove
multiple movements in a symphony for
instance there's an architecture that
goes
in proportion and what's happening in
terms of key scheme and and caught
musical content and so in looking at
those you know the composer composers
are familiar with these things that you
need to impose some kind of architecture
on on a piece that's that big to in
order for it not to die of its own way
one thing that would kill it right away
if it were the same tempo all the way
through or if they a kind of a level of
what was happening was the same any kind
of same so you need some contrast going
through that in a symphony that we might
hear there's there's very frequently a
familiar architecture to it you know
something that has been implied by
earlier works or pieces but in something
like this you have a completely
different it seems to me schema so how
how did that architecture before come to
you just from the text itself we're
doing mostly from the text pretty much
set the text and then get the singers
out so they can rest a minute and have
the orchestra come in you're shifting
things around so there's some practical
considerations right and most text
driven music will will adhere to the
text rather than saying instrumental
Sonata form that requires other types of
so as you prepare for this premiere how
what is your what is your feeling is
that one of of anticipation one of
excitement one of how do you feel as you
go through this process and work because
it doesn't really reach the completion
in a way that work doesn't reach
completion until it's performed right it
being a big piece creates a lot more
anxiety particularly when you have no
input you turn over the score and that's
that's it it's too big of an animal to
do any major alterations most of of the
alteration type things that happened
were in the last year or two where I
would sit down with mostly eric nelson
to talk about
the vocal things because vocalists have
concerns that violin players don't have
so the collaboration really proceeded
going into the whole rehearsal process
that would ended with the collaboration
began as you were developing the work
right I didn't want to give Eric the
score during spring break and ask him to
put that together that that wouldn't
work so in a way to touch base with
conductors to see if there's something
that's what they would suggest if if
something's not going to work and one
dimension you mentioned about this work
is that at the end you anticipate the
audience participating so have you ever
done anything like that before has that
been a part of your work no I've never
done that it's going back to the
religious it's kind of an evangelical
experience not a classical concert hall
experience but to make it truly
universal I thought well why why not
because there's this recurring idea that
in Egyptian that's forever and ever
forever and ever and has a simple melody
to it that this would get the people
involved what are you saying like I
old-fashioned him saying huh in a way
with the idea being that someone may
believe something or not believe
something and but into themselves they
may not be sure what it is but when they
hear themselves speak it out loud that's
a different thing then they hear
themselves saying I believe this or I
don't believe that and so maybe this is
an attempt to enjoin people to to join
in to be part of the actual process and
how do you signal that to the audience
how will they know or how does the great
detail it was a problem that that
everybody talked about for quite a bit
of time about how to set it up because
it sounds easier than it
in the main in the conductor score you
see where things repeat and then there's
some verbal explanation of in these
repeats like how many times and who's
doing what and then when that gets
through then the conductor well first
the conductor is conducting turns around
to hopefully the informed audience they
know they're coming in and he conducts
them because he's prepped them before
the concert and then when he gets
through with them hopefully they will
know and then he turns back around to go
into the coda of the thirteenth movement
or the twelfth movement to finish the
piece so the audience participation part
is it not at the very end but just prior
to this just prior to the coda yeah so
we'll see I mean there's a question of
whether they will actually make any
noise or not right well presumably some
of us will be there so we'll have an
early clue what we're supposed to do so
anything else that you'd like to say
about this work Jack about what it's
meant to you or where where it's taking
you next that would be an interesting
question where you know we're gonna see
this next week but then what happens
after that for you with this piece
either both with this piece and also
with other work that you're well I am
involved in another a number of other
works this piece will be very hard to
get staged again there's it's possible
right but that would be hard to get this
many forces together so I'll I'll
inevitably go back and add in things
which is natural and see if what I can
do with it but I have other pieces that
I'm going to be on - so how does that
feel the idea that something that you
created years and years and years of
work and effort has this this one
incarnation potentially this one
incarnation and who knows what will
happen after that is that a that's
something hard to live with or accept or
is it just the nature of
that's more the nature of your at least
the piece is done it's not just
imagining right or I mean that's a
horrible thing if you if you want to be
an artist and think well I can't do that
because blah blah or I can't do this and
so why not why do anything and being an
artist you have to by the nature of that
you've got to put yourself out in front
of people who inevitably are going to
have qualms with what what you're doing
they may like this or like that like the
conductor's they say I like this
movement I like this I don't like that
movement so much yeah so how do you
ultimately deem the work a success as
far as you're concerned what criteria do
you use to determine how you feel about
it well I guess importantly how the
composer feels about it maybe everyone
else doesn't like it but if you like it
then that's right that's good but part
of it is is it a practical piece in
terms of can the players play do they
want to play this is it interesting
there are there parts interesting or is
it just are there so many
berrak barricades so that it's going to
have difficulty the whole time and
virtually ever composers written pieces
that are just right the first time and
others that they've had to revise and
revise it's just the nature it's not a
pleasant thing but it's the nature of it
it's kind of like Rilke who says you've
got to go visit the dark side of the art
before you really encompass it and that
what that's actually kind of leads to a
final question I have for you we talked
about some influences such as when you
just mentioned a kind of literary
influences but are and in your art form
beyond the music and beyond the
literature of the text or their other
artistic or influences things that
attract your attention or something that
comes back in your consciousness
that you may not even be aware of until
it has some sort of form in the music
itself could you restate that
so other other influence influences
beyond perhaps the text or music other
kinds of art forms that are appealing to
you for me literature as always the word
has always been the most important I do
get ideas from visual arts once in a
while from nature not as much though
it's mostly the imagination with it with
the artists working with intuition and
lack of logic and intersecting with
other influences that could do that
yeah favorite question people have what
is your favorite piece of music there or
what do you what do you listen to and I
think my answer is usually disappointing
because I often say well in this piece I
like this section and this piece I like
this movement or I like this moment
rather than saying well I like this
piece from measure one and but that
could be the nature of the composer -
yeah inclined to see it and its
component parts right so again is there
anything else that you'd like to say
like us to know about this work so as we
go into it we'll be we'll be thinking
about it and in that broader context or
anything you want to say about the
experience for you and did you want to
play another another play one more okay
movement then try to answer I guess okay
that sounds great
now I have to deal with this again
you
we'll be on YouTube
this is a very
I'm getting close
this one's called the ladder to the sky
oh shoot
perpetually goes them
Oh
sorry that when the strings behind her
the most important thing but you can't
hear them in this recording so much it's
kind of planed out so what is it about
that word that pieces and the work that
where is it located in the work that's
the ninth piece and so it's reached kind
of a low point and then it then it goes
right and there's a lot of string
activity there that that helps and again
my earlier question was is that are
there is there something that you'd like
us to anything more that you'd like to
say about the work or what this
experience has been for you I'm not
think of anything offhand maybe they're
a big question
well let's open it up are there
questions from the audience
which section did you show the Muslim
which movement yes well I wrote a ball
at the same time and so I was jumping
around and quite a bit and they all kind
of came to a conclusion about the same
time that it was a matter of jumping
around what was the total amount of time
from when you actively began in the
composition yeah more or less completed
let's see about two years ago I actually
started on it full-time
before that I had I had quite a bit of
music I had done sketches in between
other pieces I am I'm always if I get
bored and I work on something else so I
had a lot of music but then about two
years ago I decided to work on a
full-time and I worked on it for a year
and then a part of big problem with what
technological problem the file got so
big it was I had to split it apart there
were just all kinds of technical things
that were occurring and still
that's because my my father's father was
a scientist who's a neurologist
and so and he's extremely strict
Catholic I came from a very strict
family and you know where you didn't get
decide what to decide what you were
going to do you were told so my father
was forced to go in he wanted to be a
writer and actually worked in Hollywood
for about six or eight years in the 30s
and he wanted to pursue that but it was
very much against what his father would
have allowed and so I think I was the
beneficiary that because I got I wasn't
told I have to be this or that of the
other I was given a little bit more free
rein
you talk a little about that the
distinction between creativity or moral
imagination versus verbal or textual
I guess they they are different I really
like the word but that is different than
sound of imagination it could be that
maybe for different people with a kid if
they're experiencing some things that's
kind of in black and white and then they
get to something that they're very
practiced at or have a real interest in
doing in it and then all of a sudden
it's in color more amplified and more
affects you more internally and then
maybe the spectrum goes on you think
about something else and it's back to
black and white and people are have
their difference strengths I guess so
maybe with a writer that would see a
certain kind of writing and it would all
open up to them and help their
imaginations but maybe a painter looking
at this would say I'm bored by what that
looks like and it's not giving me any
imagination at all
the question I'm asking I can visualize
if I'm going if I were going to be
sequences vertically expressive
action and if I were going to be a Peter
you know I have a very clear idea of
what
there is the connection where a writer
started they start with one word and
then put another word and then that
implies what the third word should be so
if you hear a sound it can be anything
but a few juxtapose some other element
to it then that relationship implies a
lot of possibilities some of them very
abstract some very simple and then by
adding in the next pitch or the next
idea then it multiplies and I think in
the process of writing you if you want
to be in that zone where you're not even
questioning or thinking about that
you're just doing and then you can come
back later to see well what did it what
did you do to capture that I remember
hanging around a Japanese painter of his
blue block and he would spend the
morning drinking coffee and smoking
cigarettes and then he would you father
approach the canvas with a lot of
whatever it is built up and and then
just captured the stroke like that and
he said that was the most important
thing because he could then go from that
but if he didn't capture the spirit and
the motion of the stroke that he had
then it couldn't go from there and
there's something about that kind of
practice trying to capture the spirit
for instance a buck like working the
piano I'm rather than putting a piece of
blank paper up and say okay I'm going to
write a 36 measure piece that does this
that and the other I wouldn't go that
way because I would be getting too much
in the way with other things of too many
considerations to think of it that way
it would be better to get the blank
piece of paper up there and capture one
idea just capture the spirit literally
get it get the basic idea on the page
because once I got if I can always go
back and develop it and see what its
relationship is to the other piece of
paper that came there from yesterday and
then after while those relationships
build up and one can see which direction
is it's going to do but I think I'm the
moment-to-moment decision it's kind of
like crossword puzzles where it just
comes to you that's what the word is
going to be you think well how did i
okay there's so many spaces and I had
this letter but still I mean how did you
come to some decision that that was the
word and it's hard to say well what
triggered that where you would come up
with the word to put in there but I
think in Envisat when you're in that
zone or writing
whatever you're working on on that kind
of level it's not a rational level
message the rationale rationality comes
maybe later
it's the irrationality or the chaos that
occurs first
with that in mind how do you teach a
composition to your students I I don't
you can't teach people how to write
music right but you have composition
students why you do with composition
students is give them the opportunity to
compose and help them with technical
elements like how do you get this
notated on the page what will work what
won't work and then let the music come
from that but I've never successfully
been able to actually teach someone
composition so you provide opportunity
for it to rise and you work on some of
the technical dimensions of that a lot
of a lot of times it's their own self
realization about one of the most
interesting things with the composition
classes I have them work with the vegas
string quartet professional string
quartet
and they the place music and then we
discuss it and to see these young
students who have never dealt with many
musicians and particularly not
professionally to actually see that
these these notes on the page don't just
get played that they rise to a level of
art to see their reaction and they learn
more from that than anything I could say
for weeks so in that way it's I think
Martin is like guys it's your own
self-realization and so when you see a
work such as this one performed you
didn't see that as a kind of not final
or concluding step in a process of
self-realization but an important part
of that whole of everything that's come
before and what's interesting is as Bob
pointed out that you really reference
back to the pyramids of your childhood
you know those conversations and not
just the scientific part of that are
measurements and all of that but all
all imaginative and far well I think
like a lot of composers when I was five
years old hearing these things I was
making up little songs too and singing
those and so it was kind of process well
thank you very much for sharing that
your your process with us something
about your life that led to this and
also the work itself which will have the
opportunity to hear and it's you know
full full translation and embodiment in
the lives of so many people of this
partners of my colleagues of us in this
community so we're very grateful for a
year the preceding program is
copyrighted by Emory University